from the studio that single-handedly
stopped Disney from making more terrible
sequels to the Emperor's New Groove
comes the animated classic that forced
every 2d animator to learn how to use a
computer or to get a new job Toy Story
revisit the film that inspired an epic
one of original Pixar movies that were
so good we all gave them a pass for cars
- and get ready for the classic
children's film that's all about
jealousy broken dreams and the
existential dread that you will one day
I'll live your purpose and be replaced
by someone newer and better you know
classic Pixar stuff return to a simpler
time when kids only had toys and their
imaginations to play with share buddy
I'm here to stop you what I thought
for a movie that would be all about a
boy and his iPad if it came out today
and witnessed the first-ever fully
computer animated feature that looks
pretty good considering it came out the
same year as Windows 95 point the mouse
at the start button bottom left and
click look Mattie I'm computing watch as
these toys come to life in a secret
society that's just as boring and unfun
as our own Tuesday night's plastic
corrosion awareness meeting was I think
a bang success that humans really should
have noticed by now bones the monkeys
are working
Caxton seriously they're not even trying
to be discreet
I mean he just passed like a hundred
houses someone would have seen him meet
woody a neurotic me egotistical control
freak you stay away from oh shut up
give me that shut up just shut up with
it moving bud shall I get one when the
much cooler toy buzz lightyear appears
he'll attempt to murder him in a jealous
rage kicking off a grand adventure of
friendship between the sad strange
little man you are a sad strange little
man and a delusional Taiwanese spaceman
who shoots first and ask questions later
I've set my laser from stun to kill ah
great great yeah everybody whatta taxes
we can blink him to death it's funny
because he's trying to kill him thrill
as they escape the clutches of Sid the
only person who's ever successfully used
a claw machine twice a creepily rendered
young boy which nineties computers
clearly weren't ready for Grinch as this
child villain whose biggest crimes are
tinkering the toys he didn't know we're
alive and acting up to get the attention
of his drunk dad is taught a lesson so
cruel it will undoubtedly scar him for
life toys
so play nice - that's messed up so get
ready to go to infinity and beyond with
the animated classic you'll end up
watching countless more times with your
own kids one day causing you to bring up
existential questions you can't help but
ask like can toys die our toys born when
do they become sentient can they have
kids do sex toys count do all toys
initially have the same mental and
philosophical breakdown as buzz if bus
has knowledge of being in space why
doesn't woody have knowledge of his
roundup gang he meets later in part to
which toys can talk and which ones can't
since to his cat but the binoculars can
and he doesn't even have a mouth does
Andy's mom realize it's super illegal to
have a baby ride in the front seat when
everybody knows that
where's Andy's dad know this he's got a
one-year-old so he must have been around
recently did he run out on him did he
die is any so attached to woody because
that's the last thing his dad gave him
before he disappeared
oh god this is getting a tense wait play
the Randy Newman song hurry
it's awful boy Thor you disarm from boy
door real
it's story by some boys they come to
life for the old boy blahblah
yadda-yadda
toys if the song from points or evil
you're watching what dory
and that's a wrap man this job is easy
hey everybody who wants to melt down
some gold records and Grammys to go for
tacos my treat I still love Italy
starring Vin Diesel inconceivable racks
choking hazards Green minions Sid
Vicious a bo peep lamp how is that a toy
long dawg silver Jon Hamm nanny for
Muppet Babies toy Hanks and Toy Story
yeah that's pretty much what it is
what's next big and moving by bugs okay
here we go
it's a bug tiny bug I like bugs
oh I think this could use the tuning be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers extra special thanks to Will
Sasso
please go show him some love by
following them in all his networking
things at Will Sasso and subscribing to
his 10-minute podcast on iTunes man I
love that guy I only need one Mr Bond I
am more powerful than any Jedi even you
you will taste manflesh leave Sauron to
me I shed the blood of Saxon men come it
is time to keep your appointment with a
wicker man